Art Magic Show le rassemblement
d'artistes de tout âge produit par
l'association de Montini le Bretonneau
ainsi solo duo et groupe se retrouent
pour partager la scène lors de concert
et spectacle de danse des artistes
soutenus par arm magique comme alpha
project mais aussi des indépendants
comme Michel j'ai rejoint pas
l'association magique mais l'association
Lavo en scène depuis un peu moins d'un
an maintenant voilà et ça se passe super
bien parce que du coup j'ai l'occasion
et la super opportunité de faire des
scènes c'est ça qui m'intéressait
progresser en chant mais aussi du coup
de de pouvoir rencontrer un public donc
et de pouvoir lui proposer donc mes
heures puisque je suis auteur et
compositeur et interprète art magique
c'est depuis 10 ans une association de
danse et de chant à l'époque il y a 10
ans dans le coin c'était difficile en
fait de trouver certains types de de
manifestation certains types de Danes
certains types de cours de danse c'est
la raison pour laquelle j'ai créé
l'association pour pouvoir en proposer
nous voulions et nous voulons monter une
école de musique et de danse y ajouter
par la suite du théâtre et dont le but
est de donner d'abord des
cours ensuite de promouvoir des gens et
de faire de la création la création
musicale et scénique pour tous ceux qui
ont manqué cette dernière représentation
prochain spectacle le 8
juin